Tamara: I have to say, it's a real treat for
me to introduce Ken
Auletta, who's written the "Annals of Communications"
column for the
New Yorker since 1992 and is here to discuss
his 11th book, which some
of you have, "Googled: The end of the world
as we know it". It chronicles
the rise of Google and its intercession with
the traditional media
world which could be of particular interest
to everyone here.
Umm, and Eric, I believe, called it one of
the most insightful
analyses of Google in a book ever.
Umm, Publishers Weekly said similarly, "It's
a sharp and probing
analysis of the apocalyptic upheavals in the
media and entertainment
industries."
NPR said it -- that "Few of its points couldn't
be discovered by
Google Search in a fraction of a second."
But interestingly, the last -- what was going
to be the last chapter
of the book is instead available for free
on Ken's web site,
Kenauletta.com, and it consists of 25 media
maxims which he deduced
from his 13 visits to Mountain View over the
last two and a half
years of researching and writing.
And, uh, so maybe he can talk to us about
why he made that decision.
So, uh, it's a pleasure to welcome him and
please join me in welcoming
Ken Auletta.
Thanks.
>> [Clapping]
Ken: Thanks, Tamara.
What Tamara didn't say was that she was one
of my handlers as I was
spending this time in -- in Mountain View
and the truth is that --
that she was great, as was her boss, David
Crane.
And I was mentioning to her something that
was true for anyone in
communications.
If you are, umm, a PR person, one of the things
that -- that I found
in my experience as a journalist, uh, you
understand implicitly that
you represent two bosses.
Your primary boss is the company you work
for, or the government you
work for, or whatever your employer is. But
you have an obligation to
the journalist as well, to tell the truth.
And, in fact, to do your job, you have to
earn the trust of that
reporter.
Because someone like David Crane or Tamara
kept me away from making
mistakes of following false leads because
trusted them.
They weren't going to lie to me.
So it made my life a lot more efficient in
setting up appointments and
everything else.
And so I thank you.
Umm, and Ellen West, in don't know if she's
here, but Ellen was also from
here.
Many of my interviews here she -- she arranged.
I was out last week, I was out in Mountain
View speaking there last
week, umm, on Thursday and on Monday of last
week I spoke with
Microsoft.
So I have regards from your good friend to
the north.
>> [Laughing]
Ken: Not.
Umm, it was actually a very interesting visit
because I had done a
book ten years ago on Microsoft.
I covered their trial and I remember, umm,
the swagger that they had
ten years ago before they were found guilty
in two federal courts.
Umm, they believed that they were advancing,
uh, a good, that they
were creating an operating system that everyone
could use, it was
uniform, and wasn't that efficient and cool?
Umm, but they weren't thinking about the law
and -- and monopoly law,
etc., strength of trade laws, etc -- and they
got caught.
And -- but they -- at the time they felt that
they were on top of the
world.
Remember, they were called the evil -- the
evil empire.
Umm, and when I went back ten years later,
last -- a week ago Monday,
I was stunned that at how tentative they had
become and how
questioning they were.
They were intently interested in finding out
more about you guys.
Tell us, what's Google like?
And that suggested a certain, you know, sweat
on the upper lip, umm,
to me.
They were -- they were much more humble, uh,
certainly friendly.
It was a very pleasant, umm, session I had
and questions and all but it
was a different company, a company that realized,
umm, that they
were -- that they had slipped some and they
had a ways to get back,
and that maybe you were, uh -- had gained
on them.
And I remember -- I tell this story at the
beginning of the second
chapter of my book with an interview I do
with Gates in '98 and I said
to him, uh, Mr. Gates, I said, what do you
worry about when you think
about the future?
What's your nightmare?
And he -- he thought deeply and as he's thinking
deeply I'm thinking
he's gonna start naming Netscape, and Oracle,
and Apple, Sun, and he
didn't.
He gently rocked back and forth after he fetched
himself a Diet Coke
in the refrigerator behind his desk -- without
thinking to offer me
one -- umm --
>> [Laughing]
Ken: Social graces is not something you often
find in engineers.
You'll forgive my insult.
Umm, I saw some of the same traits at -- at
Google.
Umm, and, uh, I didn't make a blank statement
by the way so if some of
you are engineers, umm, can be excused.
Umm, and he said, I'll tell you what I worry
about, Ken.
He said, I worry about someone in a garage
inventing something, some
new technology I've never thought about and
that -- that's my
nightmare.
And in fact in '98 two people in a garage,
uh, Larry and Sergay, and --
and they've become Microsoft's worst nightmare.
In -- in my visit to -- I liken what I do
to visiting other planets
and -- and so I liken -- I visit the Google
planet and spent time and
tried to understand the natives, and the culture,
and -- and what was
different about your company.
Umm, and then I went back and visited other
planets while I'm
reporting this book including the planet where
I had spent more time
for earlier books, umm, traditional media
planet, and tried to
understand them and how they related to you
in the digital world which
in most cases was, uh, blindfolded.
Uh, they were not -- in my judgment, had not
spend the time they
should have spent, uh, trying to ride that
digital wave that people
like you have -- have created.
And that's why they've crashed into it.
So I -- I came away from this experience visiting
that planet with a
sense that they had -- that they -- they claimed
they were being
murdered.
In fact, they were much more guilty of committing
suicide, uh, over
the years and by not being proactive, and
not making investments,
by -- I mean, you think about music companies
deciding that the -- you
can only buy an entire CD and then iTunes
comes along and -- and gives
consumers what you give them, which is choice.
And, umm, they didn't get it.
Or you think about newspapers;
They would come back, say the New Yorker,
we had online editions 15
years ago and I would say to them, you did.
I know you did.
But who was in charge of the online editions?
The editor of the print newspaper.
And were they allowed to break stories instantly
as news was
happening?
No, no.
You had to wait 'til the next morning'tll
it appeared.
And do the people running that understand
that the internet or online
was a very different medium than a newspaper?
It was multimedia, it was instant?
No.
They didn't get that either.
Did they make investments in digital companies?
Did they try and make a deal early on with
Google?
Nada.
So I learned that but I learned some things
in visiting your world.
One of the things that absolutely enthralled
me about Google is I kept
on saying to myself, where did two guys in
their 20s get such clarity
of thought?
And because when you think about it, here
are -- how did Larry Page,
and Sergay Brin, decide that they wouldn't
have ads on their home
page, unlike, say, Yahoo!?
How did they decide in their 20s, that unlike
Yahoo! or AOL that
Google was not going to be a portal?
That people did a search and they were going
to chase 'em off the Google
site to the destination of their choice?
How'd they decide that build it and they will
come?
We'll figure out a way of monetizing it.
And it took them three and a half years before
they were able to
monetize it and advertise.
But they had faith that they could do it.
How they -- how they had the sense that give
engineers 20 percent of
their time off to work on projects of their
choice and that this would
be a great innovation?
How did they come up with the idea of having
two classes of stock,
where the New York Times or Warren Buffett
does, in order not to play
the Wall Street game of short term, of considerations?
So I was just dazzled by that and I did a
fair amount of reporting to
try and figure that out and -- and, umm, and
I report that in my book.
I was also dazzled by something else, which
is as I would attend your
meetings, umm, and I would watch the engineers
speak the language that
to me was Swahili -- I mean, I literally didn't
understand half the
words that were being spoken, honestly.
But I that had the luxury of time.
I could go around and Columbo-like and say,
tell me what that -- that
word means would you please.
And it was actually really an incessant question.
I wanted to know the answer.
So I had -- I had time to figure that out.
But as I'm sitting in these engineering meetings,
two things came to
mind: One, I kept on thinking of Terry Semel,
who was the head of
Yahoo!, or originally when he took it over
in 2001 the same year as
Eric Schmidt came to -- to Google, he had
done a very good job of
settling down Yahoo!, and it did very well,
and, umm, but then Yahoo!
slipped in its engineering, as, by the way,
Apple did when John
Sculley, another non engineer, was in charge.
And you realize as you're sitting there, that's
why it slipped, 'cause
these guys couldn't understand -- like me,
they couldn't understand
the words and the language that the engineers
were speaking to them,
could not inspire them, could not challenge
them the way Larry Page,
and Sergay Brin, and Eric Schmidt, all engineers,
could.
So that really struck me as -- as -- as kind
of significant.
But also another thing struck me which is
that key to your culture and
your success -- and I'm going to talk about
some of your failures in
a -- in a minute so I'm not here to give you
wet kisses -- umm --
>> [Laughing]
Ken: But, umm, key to your success is that
the engineers are treated
like a king.
And if you think about it, one of the things
that -- the thoughts that
came over me as I'm reporting this book is
that the engineer at
Google -- the engineer at a lot of these companies,
facebook, etc. --
is often the -- a content creator, is often
the Martin Scorsese, if
you will, because those apps that they're
creating are things that
occupy people's attention.
And it's content; and why it's content is
because if I'm spending two
hours on Google Search or two hours -- or
an hour on Google Maps or I'm
spending two hours on facebook, that's an
hour or two hours I am not
spending watching CBS or reading a book.
That becomes content to me.
And -- and the content creator's a person
who's created that cool
application that's riveted my attention.
I learned something else: That the virtue
of these engineers is also
often -- and I emphasize often because I -- I
don't make -- I try not
to make sweeping generalizations -- but often
that virtue, its flip
side is that it's often advice.
And what I mean by that is that engineers
are really good at things
you can quantify and measure.
And one of the things you've done brilliantly
here is you ask a series
of questions.
You started with search.
Why can't it be more efficient?
Why do we have to have ads on home page?
Why do -- why don't we just send people off
and not treat it like a
port?
All those questions that you asked with search.
But then as you started asking other questions:
Why do advertisers --
why do clients, advertising clients, have
to pay four or 5 percent to
a media ad firm if we can do it more efficiently
and we charge them when
we click on an ad?
Why can't we have Google news and aggregate
news and provide 25,000
newspapers and magazines from all around the
world--really cool -- why
can't we digitize all the books in the world?
I mean, all these things are wonders to someone
like me.
I mean, doing a book like this without Google?
I mean, you can't do it.
I mean, I have to be getting up, and out of
my gym shorts when I'm
writing which is very -- and away from my
refrigerator, both of which
are great comforts to me, and go to the library
and, you know, it --
so it's really cool.
But -- but as you start asking all those questions
about Google Books,
and Google News, and -- and advertising and
how about for your
telephone service?
You know, and -- and how about YouTube and
television?
Why can't we get that through John Stewart.
Why can't you see it on, we're on a plane.
User generated contents or whatever.
Or cloud computing, then you start -- Google
starts to call itself not
a search company but by 2004 you were calling
yourself a media
company, which you've become.
But as you become a media company, because
you want to be able to
quantify things, just as happened to Microsoft
in '98, '99, 2000.
Microsoft, if you would say to them -- I mean,
I'll tell you, this
literally happened to me talking to Bill Gates
when I'm reporting that
Microsoft book.
He said, how can the government question my
-- Microsoft's intentions?
How could they think we're trying to do evil
-- they didn't use the
word "evil" but -- but actually that was a
phrase that was affixed
to -- as you know well, to Microsoft back
in that point in time.
He was generally outraged.
It was not an act on his part.
He was generally outraged by it.
And because he and -- and -- and Steve Ballmer
and the people at
Microsoft couldn't understand why people might
fear the size of
Microsoft and might, in looking at their e-mail
traffic -- which was
all on display in that courtroom -- uh, why
people might feel that
they were acting like thugs.
Umm, they thought they were advancing some
kind of social group.
And I think similarly you have been very late
to understand at Google
the fears that your size and dominance creates.
Now, you're not -- as Eric Schmidt often said
to me when I would pose
this question -- and I think he's right -- people
are only one click
away from dropping Google.
and that's true, unlike Microsoft.
You can't, 95 percent of the operating systems
as they had, you couldn't just
drop Microsoft.
you needed access.
so there is a difference and I'm not claiming
comparability.
I'm not claiming the sameness but I am claiming
some comparability and
the comparability is that they didn't understand,
at Microsoft, the fear if
they aroused.
And Google has been late to understand that
fear.
but it's not just -- it's not just the issue
of size or concentration
of power.
You've got two other issues that you face
that are potentially atomic.
One is privacy.
You create -- you create or collect a mountain
of data on people from
all of your various applications, not just
Search.
That is a tremendous amount of information.
As you know, there are countries in Europe
that have more stringent
privacy regulations than we do and the fears
are even greater.
But that fear will rise and it will rise not
just because of what you
do but because of what advertisers increasingly
demand.
And in fact when you talk to advertisers,
as I do for this book, or
you talk to the telephone companies, as I
do for this book, or the
cable companies, as I do for this book, it's
quite astonishing what
they -- the brave new world they envision
or what they will do with
the data.
Not just your data, but the data that every
cable box has or the data
that -- that -- that -- that every telephone
company has, and your
create card numbers, and lots of other material
about what you do.
what you watch, how long, what you like, what
you buy, etc.
And that will -- that is going to create a
conflict as sure as we're here
today between governments, or other businesses,
or the public
concerned about privacy.
The third potential atomic issue that I think
you face and that I
think you have not been as sensitive as you
might have been was -- is
copyright.
I mean, you saw that -- you -- you will be
in a court soon if they
don't settle- and I don't think you will-
with Viacom over YouTube, where
they've sued you for a billion dollars.
You were sued, uh, for a period of time by
the publishers and the
authors guild.
You settled that and yesterday the judge,
uh, allowed it to go forward
until a hearing in February when the Justice
Department has to weigh
in as to whether they concur with the settlement.
But you were going to have a lawsuit there
had you not relented and
understood that there were copyright issues
here and your definition
of "fair use", you were pushing too far.
And -- and -- and similar things are gonna
happen.
You see Murdoch threatened you with -- you
know, the pull of all his
newspapers, not just, you know, from Search
as well as from Google
News, etc.
That issue will -- will rear up and, you know,
a lot of these old media
guys are gonna come hat and hand and say,
"Make my business whole."
That's not Google's responsibility to make
them whole.
And there are a lot of newspapers you would
not want to, you know,
contribute money to.
But, I don't know, when Larry Page says to
me, as he did and as I report
in this book, you know, we depend -- for search,
we depend on good
information and so we have a real stake in
the New York Times
surviving and some other -- and the Wall Street
journal and others --
he mentioned the Times specifically.
And, you know, that -- so the New York Times
is going to go hat in hand,
at some point, as the Wall Street journal
would and say, if you have a
stake in us for good search, shouldn't you
be subsidizing?
And the problem, of course, that you're gonna
confront is you're gonna
have the trail behind them of every newspaper
in the world who said
they want, you know, they want support and
subsidy, and you're not going to
do that.
That's not your responsibility.
But you're will be confronted with some big
issues about, uh, whether
you share in that information.
Now, I can say in the short term that it is
terrific for us as -- as
users to be able to search and get access
to any newspaper story in
the world.
It really -- it -- it -- I mean, it's just
a wonderous thing for me to
be able to search books or academic journals,
wonderful thing.
But one of the questions in the future is,
if the New York Times, for
instance, doesn't survive, and other really
estimable newspapers
don't survive, and they can't maintain bureaus
in Kabul, or Baghdad,
or can't spend two or three months doing an
investigative report, then
I don't think the blogosphere can replace
that kind of journalist, which
we, as citizens, all have a stake in.
Interestingly enough, Larry Page has thought
a lot about this and I
had a long conversation about this with him
and he was reading some
books on -- on journalism at the time and
was really concerned about
it.
Now, how do you translate that kind of concern
into some kind of an
action?
I don't know the answer to that and he obviously
didn't when we were
talking.
But in my last interview in Mountain View,
which was April 1st, umm, and
it wasn't a joke even though it was April
Fool's day, I left Eric Schmidt's
office and I went down to the cafeteria and
who do I bump in to but Arthur
Sulzberger, Jr., the proprietor -- the owner
-- the proprietor of the New
York times, and he was going up to see Eric,
and they were trying to
figure out is there some way that we could
provide more help to the
Times without busting our bank, and without
taking responsibility for
all the mistakes the Times and other papers
have made?
And that, I know, is an ongoing discussion.
But it's one that I think- whether you work
at Google or not- we all
have a stake in -- in -- in having good journalism.
When I spend -- before I -- I -- I open the
questions, when I look at
the future, which I try to do at the end of
-- of this book, umm, I
think you're a great company.
Umm, I think Microsoft's a great company.
Umm, but you're right now a greater company
than they are, and you do amazing things.
Umm, you -- but you -- you are gonna face
some huge issues.
Umm, one of them I've just mentioned which
is that that sensitivity
gene- which is not always exhibited at Google-
will be challenged as you
go forward by governments, by other companies,
uh, and by the public,
uh, on issues like privacy.
And -- and that's going to be a real challenge.
You -- you know the challenge you face as
you get big and success.
you start losing good people, people want
to get with a start up where they
have an opportunity.
If they came here after 2004 to maybe make
a killing, maybe
to have a bigger job responsibility, maybe
because they're frustrated,
they feel some of the people above them are
-- are -- have lost some
energy.
So they want to move on.
You're going to have some challenges with
-- with -- with users just as
Microsoft did.
With the sense of -- you know, it's a -- you
live in a very cloistered
world.
You get free food.
You know, out there, I mean, you get massages,
and -- and car washes,
and oil changes, and physicians.
I don't know how many of those services you
have here.
I assume you have many of them.
Umm, it's quite a -- a cloistered, comfortable
world.
But it's a world where it is very easy, particularly
if you've had the
success and growth you've enjoyed, it's very
easy to -- to get full of
yourself and lose the humility that I think
anyone in any business,
particularly journalism, which is about asking
questions and not
having the answers before you ask the questions,
umm, that needs to
function in this world.
So I -- I think as great as you are and as
ambitious as you are, and
all the cool things you do, you are a challenged
company and -- and --
and as -- as some of the old media folks that
I write about are
challenged in a much more severe way, up,
ask it's -- it's always
useful to remember that as you, uh, as you
think about how that stock
is at $700 a share.
Anyway, I'd love to take your questions and
thank you.
>> [Applause]
>> Hi.
Thanks for coming.
Question, though.
Now, it turns out that knowing the future
and even preparing for it --
knowing the future has a limited utility and
in the specific area that you
were talking about there.
Uh, for instance, I'm from a large -- surprisingly
large, I think
and constantly growing group of people who
for well over the last
15 to 20 years, okay, has been taking a sincere
interest in, umm,
in -- in an industry that we're in the process
of disrupting, and that
is the mainstream media, the traditional media
of journalism and such,
and we've been constantly warning these people
of what would happen,
how they should prepare for it, how they should
compete with us, how
they should work with us, etc.
Umm, in fact, my gut feel is I don't think
in history, okay, any group
of disrupters has ever had such a deep and
principled interest in the
industry that they are disrupting nor given
it so much energy and
assistance in trying to keep it going.
But we've been consistently ignored, we've
been consistently -- uh,
all the advice has been consistently rejected,
and we're talking onto
two decades probably of the -- the conversation
here being noisy.
Now, we're at the point now where people sort
of are finally beginning
to realize there really is a problem.
The stuff we were telling them back in the
early 90s, it's happening.
So, the question is, for you, because you've
been in this business for
a long time, how can we get them to listen
to what we're saying and
what in the world, at this point, can you
suggest that we might be
able to do to keep journalism going?
Because 20 years of advice has simply been
ignored.
Ken: Umm, it's a very good question and I
wish I had a very good answer.
I don't have a simple answer for that.
I mean, one of the things -- I -- I -- I came
away from this book
believing is a long-winded way of answering
your question.
My -- one of the differences between you guys
and Microsoft.
Microsoft were cold businessmen.
They were people who really wanted to kill
their competition.
Google, I think, is composed much more of
-- of cold engineers and
they're -- they're -- they're looking for
efficiencies and you've
looked for efficiencies.
Now, you have said-- to introduce the point
you made -- you said despite the fact
that I say you're cold engineers and that's
a much more of a
complement than saying a cold businessman
obviously -- that you're
saying you tried to reach out to traditional
media and -- and work
with them.
And there's some evidence of that and I produce
some in the book of
meetings that were held.
Umm, they -- a reason I -- I think they committed
suicide more than
they were murdered is because they didn't
get it.
They didn't -- they weren't proactive, they
didn't figure out that we
have to reach -- do something in the digital
world and maybe we have
to grab on to the Google hand whether it was
outreached or not.
And what they do now I think one of the things
you're going to -- we're
going to be facing -- and I -- I think this
is a real shift that's taking
place in the valley -- there's a -- a growing
willingness to accept
the notion of pay, not just advertising as
the means of paying for,
umm, for things online.
And that ultimately if -- if true -- and let
me just give you some
evidence why I think it is true -- could actually
be a bit of a life
raft for traditional media.
Let me just say what I mean.
You're shaking your head.
Tell me why you're shaking your head.
>> [Quiet]
>> The news that most people care about, at
least the news for the
public, is essentially the tip-of-the-iceberg
news.
It's the -- out of any industry, say you take
pharmaceutical, take computers business,
whatever, there's a vast amount of news that
happens on any particular
day.
The vast majority of -- of it is only of interest
to people that are
in the industry.
The stuff that the newspapers work with is
the tip of the iceberg,
it's the few hot stories.
Unfortunately, the few hot stories, for the
most part, the bulk of
their material -- the bulk of what they cover,
not the investigative
reporting -- those few hot stories are very
easy to find, they're very
easy to discover, and as a result there's
tremendous -- there's a low barrier
of entry to find them.
So competition will commoditize the tip-of-the-iceberg
news.
There is a business -- and there always has
been -- a tremendous
business in the deep news.
Organizations like the Bureau of National
Affairs, Congress
Clearinghouse, Nature Publishing Organization,
etc., they make
tremendous amounts of money in newsletters,
make tremendous amounts of
money in -- on the deep news.
But the -- and that business is going on and
will continue.
The business we're concerned about is public
journalism which,
unfortunately, is the tip-of-the-iceberg news
and that stuff is --
will be exceptionally difficult for anybody
to get enough of a
competitive and sustainable advantage that
they can charge for.
Ken: I -- I wasn't just talking about news
-- newspapers, by the way.
I mean, if -- take a look what you're doing
on YouTube.
YouTube increasingly is -- realized that -- that,
the engineers made a
mistake at YouTube.
The engineers thought that if you have the
traffic, advertisers will
come.
They weren't coming.
You were projected to lose $500 million at
YouTube this year.
You've reduced those losses dramatically.
Still going to lose money this year.
And the reason you reduced losses is you have
more professional
contact.
When I went to Eric Schmidt for my next to
last interview back in
December -- last December, I said, John Hennessy,
the President of
Stanford, who's on the board of Google said
to me, he believes the
mistake that was made early on in the internet
is that we didn't
charge, that we're too reliant on advertising.
One of the things that you see from recession
is that advertising
dollars shrink and people become more alarmed
and worried, also more
dependent on advertising which is another
source for work.
Do you agree with -- with Hennessy.
He said, I don't.
I think free is the right model.
In my last interview with Eric in April, I
said, Eric, do you still agree
with what you said to me in December?
He said, no.
I've changed my mind.
He said, I think you need another -- source
of income.
And that's what you're doing.
I -- I bet you you're going to start having
some sort of subscription
model on YouTube, some sort of payment model
on YouTube at some point
in the future.
That -- that's just -- that's in terms of
-- because one of the things
you realize is that the advertiser needs a
friendly place -- a
predictable place to put their friendly ads,
A, but B you want to have a
multiple source of income.
You don't want to make the same mistake broadcasting
made.
Broadcasting shrinks in part because it has
a single source of
revenue, advertising. Cable is a much more
robust business because it
also has a subscription model.
And I think you're gonna be moving that.
Now, your point about newspapers becoming
commod -- news becoming
commoditized I think that's largely true and
that's a real problem,
uh, for them.
But I -- I -- I think if you look long-term,
not short-term -- and
maybe there's no good solution to this; but
I think you've got to try to
find one and you've got to do some things
including testing some -- some
pay models, being with the Kindle or whatever
-- but and -- and -- and
maybe some revenue models with the -- with
the Google, umm, that you
can never replicate Dexter Filkins in Afghanistan
for the New York
Times.
Never.
You can never replicate the kind of deep,
investigative reporting where
someone -- I mean, take -- take a look with
the New York Times.
They did seven parts on the reporter David
Rohde who was -- who was
kidnapped in Afghanistan.
And he wrote seven days of the most extraordinary
stories and
stories, by the way, I would argue that you
got a better glimpse at
who the Taliban was and what their motivations
were than any other thing I've
ever read about them.
You can't replicate that.
And -- and we, as citizens, have an interest
in preserving that.
Whether we can is another question.
Ken: You want the last word?
>> [Laughing]
>> Well, I -- I think -- I think you can replicate
it and I think the
problem is that people haven't tried.
Just to be really brief, pool reporting.
If you cut down the number of people who are
in the area, umm, of a
particular area, they can sell the content.
For instance, if you had an organization,
umm, that specialized in the
Afghan war news, it would have a lot of output
-- lot of -- lot
of -- lot of different markets that it could
sell the content into.
Some of them would be deep content markets,
others would be, uh,
tip-of-the-iceberg markets.
Umm, there's a tremendous number of ways to
monetize news about
Afghanistan.
Uh, what we haven't seen so far is people
who go into the business of
do things like monetizing the news about Afghanistan.
Uh, they're trying to continue the old models
of, you know, how do I
distribute this stuff for free?
Umm, we don't have, for instance, the New
York Times.
Yeah.
They produce these great written reports.
Okay.
But they're only doing what goes in the newspaper.
They're not, for instance, also building out
the deep news, they're
not holding the conferences, they're not holding
-- they're not doing
all the other 27 ways of monetizing a news
organization.
They're only doing the one thing that they've
done in the past.
And that's the problem.
They keep thinking that they're in the newspaper
business instead of
being in the news business.
Ken: I don't -- I don't disagree with anything
you've just said.
>> If you're in the news business, you can't
monetize -- [Inaudible]
Ken: Yeah.
The only -- the only qualification I would
have to what you said is
that -- and I -- again, it goes back to the
thesis -- I don't think
these people have been inventive at all.
I think they've been reactive.
But, I mean, there are some brilliant people
like Clay Shirky, the NYU
professor who writes a brilliant blog and
he said the issue isn't the
New York Times.
It's journalism.
How do you preserve good journalism?
And I think one of the things that -- that
Clay misunderstands and a
lot of people, and perhaps you are guilty
of this as well -- is that
not understanding that good journalism is
not an individual effort.
Just as what you do here is not an individual
effort.
It's a team effort.
When I want to do a story for the New Yorker,
let's say, I talk to a
couple of editors; right, and we kick around
ideas, and then when I
hand in that piece I am getting feedback and
they're saying to me,
"You buried your lead and it's on Page 13."
Or, "I don't think you've personalized this
enough" or -- or whatever.
Their -- their input is very important to
that product.
But it's not just them.
As the piece is going through edits, other
editors are looking at it.
And then fact checkers at the New Yorker -- which
is not typical in
that sense of other institutions -- are doing
it.
And then the copy editor is getting it.
So it becomes a team effort.
It's my name on the piece but it's a team
effort that helped produce
it.
And if you think about newspapers, you're
standing around, you're
getting ideas from people at -- in that news
room.
And -- and it's incredibly valuable.
Umm, and -- and I think at -- I think people
who are -- who -- who
know more about technology than they do about
journalism fall into the
trap of -- of missing that truth.
That's the argument I would make.
Yes, sir?
>> Hi there.
Uh, in your reporting on the book -- and I
confess I haven't read it.
I apologize.
Uh ... yes.
Uh, were you particularly inclined to speak
to regulators and, you
know, in the governments do you feel that
our future will -- where --
where do you see regulation and in our -- in
our industry and our
business fitting together?
Do you think the government is going to be
an important protector of
consumer rights, especially when it comes
to privacy?
Do you think the government will increasingly
be an inept gate keeper
of progress?
How do you see that relationship evolving?
Ken: I think I describe the government in
my book as a "great bear"
and -- and it can really hurt you, uh, much
more than Microsoft can
and some of the people you compete against.
And, uh, and it's not just this government.
It's the European Union, and it's China, and
-- and Thailand, and
whatever -- whatever government you go to.
The -- the -- there is a belief that I encountered
at Google that
things are going to be cool in the future
because your friend Obama is in
the White House and he made that great talk
in 2007 at -- in Mountain
View and -- and people loved that.
And Eric is one of his advisers, and David
Drummond, among others, is a long-time
fervent supporter.
But I think you, you at your peril would forget
that Democrats tend to
be in favor of regulation, umm, and -- and
Republicans tend to be
favor of less regulation.
And because these issues are so atomic- privacy,
compensation, power,
copyright- you're going to see more moves
toward regulation.
And -- and don't forget you've got a lot of
industries who've got a
lot of power in a place like Washington.
Think about the National Association of Broadcasters.
Think about newspapers.
What do these people do?
They have influence on members of Congress
not just because they do
lobbying, right, and because they make campaign
contributions -- the
newspapers do less of that -- they have influence
because they are the
platform for these people to make their public
speeches.
I want coverage.
So -- and it's not just them.
It's advertisers, and Microsoft, and a lot
of other companies.
So you've got a lot of forces out there that
are going to be arguing for
more regulation.
And so you've just got to be more aware and
more sensitive as you have
been in the past to this great bear.
And also the bear can be a dumb bear.
You know?
Bear often doesn't know what it's doing and
they just wanna do
something. I mean, and that's another danger.
Umm ...
>> [Silence]
>> Hi.
My name's Rob.
I have a copy of your book --
Ken: You what?
>> I have a copy of your book next to my bed.
I'm just getting through Bill Simmons' Basketball"
book first but
yours is next.
Umm, my question is perhaps a little more
specific version of that
question.
And, umm, I know Microsoft in the 90s, early
90s, would have been
flabbergasted if you had told them that the
specific practice of
bundling internet explorer with Windows was
monopolistic.
We- I think in this company also -- we would
also have a similar view that
we're not really doing anything monopolistic
or that denies choice.
What's -- but what specifically do you think
is our blind spot in
terms of a prac -- a specific practice that
we engage in that you
think people perceive as monopolistic or is
going to expose us to
antitrust scrutiny?
Do you have any ideas on that?
Ken: Uh, I -- I -- I don't think -- I think
Microsoft was a monopoly.
Umm, I don't think you are.
I mean, I think -- I'm much more prone to
accept Eric Schmidt's
argument that people are one click away from
changing their search
engine.
I don't think you lock people in.
Umm, I think, though, that -- that you -- you
would miss something
that's historically true in America, that
people are afraid of power.
And people tend not to like power.
Just look at the debate on Wall Street about
Wall Street today in
America.
There's a tremendous rise -- and you see it
in the attacks on -- on
the Secretary of Treasury yesterday in the
Congress.
There's a tremendous rise of populous outrage
that you save Wall
Street: what about us?
What have you done?
And the true is, the Obama administration
set out not to save Wall
Street but to save the American economy and
Wall Street, they felt,
had to be saved.
They're not naturally prone to love Wall Street.
But nevertheless if you did a survey or a
poll today I think you would
find a majority of people think we -- we bailed
out -- unfairly bailed
out Wall Street and that's a reflection in
part not just of the
economic climate of the times but about power.
And you have power.
You have, you know, dominance in search, you
have all this information
on people in the data that you've collected,
uh, you're expanding
into other industries which displaced them
and arouse fears.
So fear is something you can't quantify but
it's there.
And it's historically there in America about
power but you -- you've
aroused it.
Do I think you're guilty of -- of abuse of
power?
No.
I -- I -- in the reporting I did, I didn't
encounter that.
That okay?
That answer your question?
>> Yeah.
I was just interested in if you think we have
any blind -- specific
blind spots or specific practices that come
across to you as -- as --
as an observer as sharp or anticompetitive
and it sound like you don't
think there any.
Ken: I -- again, anticompetitive I didn't
find but blind spots I
found.
I report on lots of them in my book, which
you'll read after you
finish the other one.
>> [Laughing]
>> Few days away.
>> [Quiet]
>> First of all, thanks again for coming.
Uh, we briefly -- when I was up there -- spoke
about privacy and the
issues that you've alluded to during your
speech here.
Umm, one of the other points that you raised
was the fact that media
needs to figure out additional ways to monetize
and you also alluded to
the fact that in your visits to Mountain View
some of the lingo of the
engineers was, you know, incomprehensible
and I think it is, too, a
lot of us in this room who are non engineers
but the technology that
we discuss every day, uh, even the non technologists
among us do
understand it in a way that people outside
these walls may not.
Umm, I guess a two-part question.
One, given the fact that media is struggling
to survive in this
economy, any regulation or a lot of regulation
that's being bandied
about that focuses on privacy would deprive
media of -- of a revenue
stream that they currently have.
So, umm, do you think that the regulatory
environment is being
sensitive to that issue, and secondly --
Ken: I wanna be sure I understand first that
I understand the
sensitivity of the issue.
Any regulation of privacy would do what?
>> I think that certain privacy regulations
that would, uh, decrease
the ways in which revenue -- that advertising
could be used on certain
web sites and data can be collected may take
revenue streams away from
the publishers who are monetizing their inventory.
Ken: Right.
>> Umm, and so one -- my question is, one,
do you think that
regulators are sensitive to that particularly
when media is trying to
survive.
And then secondly, do you think that they
understand the technology
well enough to be able to permit certain practices
that aren't harmful
in the way that they might potentially overshoot
like we saw in
spyware legislation that brought in technology
that was not spyware in
the sense that people were concerned about?
Ken: The answer to your questions are no,
and no.
And the explanation for those answers are,
every -- every issue --
most every issue you deal with, the -- the
answer is a balance in one.
You have rights that are in collision here.
You have industries that are in collision
here.
And so what you want are sophisticated people
who can make balanced
judgments.
The privacy issue.
Umm, yes.
Behavioral advertising and a lot of other
new ways of targeting
consumers and making sure there's less waste
in the advertising
message, uh, are much more efficient.
And -- and -- and you could even imagine -- which
these people have
talked to me about and I have reported this
in the book -- you can
imagine a system where they say, "Dear consumer,
if you will give up a
little of your privacy, we'll be willing to
subsidize some services to
you that'll help us gather information about
you and what you like.
You want free HBO?
Time-warner will give it to you in return
for that."
We go down a list of things you might subsidize.
It's a balancing act.
And -- and -- and -- and only government could
-- can make that
balancing act.
And -- and then the question is, does government
have the
sophistication and judgment to do it and will
it be done in a
thoughtful way or in a kind of rushed, haphazard,
panicky, political
way.
And I -- I fear the latter, actually.
Umm, but I think there are really profound
issues of privacy that are
coming -- you just see what street view.
I mean, people suddenly are saying what?
What's going on here?
You know, it's not that anything hideous is
going on.
but it's a change.
And, I mean, I got the other day a ticket
in the mail saying --
with -- with three pictures on it and it was
me -- me -- me in my
car -- you didn't see me but you saw my -- you
saw my car and you saw
my license plate going -- just -- I was in
the crosswalk when the red
light had turned.
So they caught me passing a red light and
they said in print form, uh,
"Dear Mr. Auletta, you passed a red light
on 68th and Third Avenue,
these are the pictures.
Uh, it's a 50-dollar fine and no points on
your license."
They -- they -- they caught me.
I paid and I went in.
But I was actually astonished by that.
You know, it's not- and there are pictures
and cameras everywhere.
And these will increasingly raise issues for
the public and for
government.
And whether they're dealt with in a balanced
thoughtful way is one of the
questions.
But they're -- they're really serious issues
of privacy.
>> Absolutely.
And I'm certainly not intending to diminish
the -- the intricacy or
the significance of these issues but there
is, as you point out, a
degree of understanding that's necessary to,
uh, make sure the balance
is properly struck.
Ken: I understand.
What people don't understand is that they
say well just opt out of cookies you know,
and -- and -- I say, oh really? You want to
sign on and go through the laborious
process all the time?
I like it when I go to Google and search and
it gives me "do you
mean?"
And the only reason that you know that is
because you know something
about my searches and that's -- that's -- I
mean, if I say, "jobs"
they know I'm -- I'm inquiring about Steve
Jobs, not employment.
>> Thanks again.
Ken: Thank you.
Hi.
>> So, one of the teams that I work with is
Google Health and I
wonder if you had any thoughts on Google's
umm, activities in this
space.
We're working obviously with personal health
records, electronic
health records.
The Obama administration and Washington at
large asked us to weigh in
a lot.
I just wondered what you thought about that.
Ken: I think it's great.
I mean, I interviewed the person -- the doctor
that Google hired to
run the program in Mountain View and I think
what you're doing, what
Microsoft is competitively doing, I think
that's fabulous.
I mean, I think some efficiencies are really
great and serve --
efficiencies are really great and serve the
public and that's an
efficiency, I mean, that I can have at my
fingertips, my records that
I can share with doctors or that I can search
and find relevant
information that relates to my health, I mean,
it's a miracle.
>> Do we need to be in that space in that
capacity or should we just
be doing the trends trends and search-related
health queries and
things of that nature?
Ken: If you could do it good -- I mean, the
same question applies to
Google Books.
I mean, who else was gonna digitize 20 million
books?
You're willing to do it.
God bless you.
It's very expensive to do that.
And so, you know, I don't want government
getting in the way of that and -- and,
umm, it's real cool.
But then there are going to be some privacy
issues and they have --
the -- the government referee -- the government
is -- is not a player
in the game, but a referee and they have to
blow the whistle if
there's a foul.
And one of the fouls you look for is privacy.
And -- but you won't understand that privacy
is changing just as I
learned when I got that ticket in the mail.
So you want to -- you want to have people
who are thoughtful hopefully.
But I -- I think what you're doing is great,
personally.
I -- I said I'd tell one story.
You asked me to tell a story and then I'll
-- I'll let you go back to
work and make more money.
Umm, the reason I didn't put the last chapter
in the book, umm, is
that I -- it -- it basically is it -- it tries
to distill 25 -- came
to 25, I didn't know it would -- but I came
up with 25 what I call
"media maxims" or things that I learned from
visiting your planet but
also from visiting over the years the different
media planets I've
covered.
And I -- so I wrote this and I -- I -- it
was going to be my last
chapter.
It's one of the things -- one of the interesting
problems you have as
a writer when you're writing a book about
-- it's not a biography
where someone dies and you have the end.
You don't have a natural ending for a book
like this.
And so I thought maybe the way is to end it
by -- by doing that rather
than the way I do end it which is the future
and where -- where things
might be going.
Umm, but as I wrote it and -- and I was happy
with it.
It's about 35 pages long I'm -- I'm guessing,
umm, I looked at it and
I said, I think it -- it -- it breaks up the
narrative.
The book tends to be a narrative and this
is not a narrative.
But also it makes it look like it's a -- it's
a how-to book and it
feels very commercial, as if I'm trying to
get the best of another
world- meaning selling books in the how-to
section as well as the
business or sociology section- and I just
felt uncomfortable.
My editor -- my editor violently disagreed
with me and -- and wanted
to keep it in.
But basically was a nonquantifiable decision
that was based on my
instincts, which could be wrong, but they
were mine and it's my name
on the book so screw the publisher.
So --
>> [Laughing]
Ken: That's why -- that's why it was like
that.
Anyway, I could not have done a book like
this without the cooperation
of a company like Google and -- and for that
I'm grateful as I say in
the book.
I mean, Google was very cooperative.
Whether -- I would hope that they're not entirely
pleased and I would
not have done my job as a journalist if -- if
the people you write
about are entirely pleased and I said that
all the way through --
through the book.
But it -- it -- you have a miraculous company
and it was great fun to
visit your planet and now I'll move onto another
one.
Thank you.
>> [Applause]